welcome to the CEO playing hard for 13
with no flag that's that's a spoiler I
always like to guess those flags Minh
okay Kings Indian John maybe the main
line I came the coach no variation
always leading to a intricate play yeah
g-form jump that's a bit of a spoilsport
line it keeps the the kingside closed
and tries to still attack on the
queenside black can do his usual thing
and he has some ideas with which
sacrifices on g4 but they're not working
in in all cases let's let's see not one
hundred percent sure how to play here
you can also sometimes give this check
effectively
I don't know maybe he's just taking it
yeah let's uh let's play it at least if
he moves the king it's not helping
White's coordination if he giving up
this dark squared Bishop makes it a bit
more difficult for white to open up the
Queen side because it would also give my
bishop some like c5 takes bishop jakes
okay am I going to take s I am and now
they are the night maybe to g5 or it sir
is there some some some direct way to to
play here ignite h5 or something
sometimes you can do that with Queen g5
check and and so on but it does not look
like it's possible yeah should I put the
knight on d5 he might play Knight f2 I
don't know g5 I've rook g6 oh that's not
a problem yeah if he takes I will take
with the bishop which makes sure that
this piece is not in tuned ok iOS is it
or does he have the cynical idea to just
shut everything down and make a draw
here ok maybe now you could argue that
c6 is good for white as it is not going
for that ok
yeah I'm not sure about this position
maybe I'm just worse on the queenside
and I don't have any attack that's
that's certainly possible let's consider
is maybe I should I should just play age
32 to open something up there don't turn
I don't know
now he's going to go here to my queen
side okay maybe I can play for some
tricks pusher b5 looxcie aid I always I
want to work with Roxy three here
I I would love to have this Bishop going
to be 6 someth sometime I thought rook
c3 was good isn't it I really wanted to
prevent that Wow no they didn't pick
this it didn't play voluntarily but
maybe it's still I'm still tricky maybe
age three and queen age fire yeah okay
and each I need to to get some some
activity p.m. this is the check here
check so what now I mean I can take a
six covering here yeah that's a good
idea if it goes rook c7 I have the needy
i have this trick it's bushes in hissar
look here is a liability yeah that's the
king's indian for you full full of dirty
tricks
TJ AG requested now that I don't know it
wasn't mouse flip I guess I I do mind
doing that it's getting back requested
it's really hang back accepted it's
winning anyway I guess I'm not quite
sure where he wanted to go maybe he just
he just hit hit the square accidentally
okay what does this idea Brooke a green
c7 maybe my ideas rook g7 Queen a 82 a 1
this type of type of a check time
learning that's also Queen a 6 possibly
it shouldn't be too bad
yeah I think you have to smart move
function activated and then you if you
if you put if you press or you click on
on a square we're only in one piece can
go to it will put the it will put the
piece down and this way played rugger
gave seven I have this function
deactivated now for a while because it
costs me so many points like that it
speeds up the play but it sometimes cost
you and in some very ridiculous ways
yeah if it takes now I'm going to Winnie
form and all pawns him and the night
does not have a square anyway getting go
to h1 check and just playing this in
this this technical way yeah the beep on
but I hope that my pawns are charges
more more dangerous
how long check na dou what the heck
check check check check I don't know i
am telling what what did i do here check
but go ahead as Queen a5 checkmate I
don't know can I can i play for win
somehow king he ate check gras offered
light forfeits of your time yeah I don't
know I mean maybe I'm winning maybe I'm
winning here I don't know I can this is
I don't think I must accept the drawing
necessarily i came the computer says
it's a draw it i thought maybe i can i
can i can go go here like this this is
possible check i'm always threatening to
promote myself I thought maybe here I
it's it's a drug it's the draw yeah I
wasn't I wasn't sure really i wasn't
sure i thought maybe i can i can win
this wow the be porn I win edge I just
plated check badly I guess I of course
Bush of a seven yayaya of course be sure
a.m.
yeah I thought okay why give up anything
here but the thing is i can i can now
play here and this is just an easy win
i'm promoting with the check check and
this is just just just a very easy
winner okay and what I did is the draw I
guess check check yeah that sets a draw
wow what a game yeah okay I mean [ __ ]
check yeah okay what it was always win
it's always it's just a bit trickier
with the deep on besides the fact that
he had played rue gets them all right
thanks for watching